okay so even human capital aside dollar
for dollar do you think donations to
Yale can compare an impact to donations
say to bed nets covering children in
Africa who are dying from malaria um yes
I do I think that you know personally I
choose a couple of select causes that I
give my money to be on dl I do give TL
nancial II and it's probably important
to support if there's something that
you're very interested in that you see
and that's a great example of something
that's got a low cost and a high impact
itself and I think that's important but
what I would say about Yale is Yale can
often it's almost like basic research of
course which goes on here you know I'm
very interested in maintaining financing
for basic research beyond the what will
it do for me in a way it's I don't care
what the impact is right because most of
what we've learned in medicine over the
last hundred years has come from people
doing basic creatures where they had no
idea where I was going so I would say
that that's Yale I think that Yale is
doing specific projects you can point to
I really like that they're doing that
that they're educating the Chinese
educators but on the other hand I think
they're also doing things that are
inspiring thought they are also doing
basic research not just in the sciences
but in other areas and it's important to
support this kind of institution and I
support this one because it's where I
went does that answer the question
individual